台灣股市重霸及散戶巨人節
今天首度露面分享投資心法
他舉例如果美國總統候選人川普
要對台積電課徵更多關稅
影響的不只是一檔股票而已
上周下游概念股也會受到波及
因此股市研究需要從上到下
由里到外
而且如果進場里游消失的話
就得要及時止损
我會叫巨人節
單純是因為我
因為我的名字有節浪比較高
所以叫巨人节这样
身高190公分
笑容腼腆的介绍自己
他是台湾投资人最好奇的
一级散户巨人节
看起来还不太熟悉面对镜头
不过很多人应该对他的名字不陌生
这次他为了版税捐赠活动
首度现身露面
大家知道我是因为
我的短线交易量比较大
但是我长线也有在做
可能就几个月的
赚个股的价差波段这样
回顾2021年
光是他一个人
成交量就达到3000亿元
更在航运股热潮中
以占成名
今年截至目前为止
也已经达到1500亿的成交量
他把股市交易员
当成一份专职工作
即使陈伽利业
一天仍然投入10个小时
研究股票
从国内研究到海外川普可能要对台积电多课征关税那因为这样的关系那对于台积电就会影响那台积电是加权指数中成分最大的个股
那它有三十几%的关系
那如果它
而且尤其它的供应链很多
那它的上中下游
或是它的相关概念股都很多
那如果台积电行情不好的话
那其他个股的表现也不会很好
所以我的投资一定是会从上到下
这样去做分析
侃侃而谈分享自己的投资心法
同时巨人节也提到
虽然现在股市颇通剧烈
但对于喜欢当冲的他来说
价差变大反而更好操作
当然他也提醒
投资最重要的事情就是一定要射线
停损对我来说就是
进场的理由消失就停损
假设因为前阵子台积链上一千块
那一千块的时候
大家会往上
例如看好
看好其他的同族群的个股
包括设备也好
或是一些先进封装
这些跟台积电有关的个股
但是台积电前阵子破1000块了
那表示你的进场理由消失
那你就可以做停损动作
透过频繁交易累积经验值
在全球金融情势不稳定的情况下
操作策略也更加考验国海闯荡功力
记者黄友柔陈玉智台北采访报道